l'armée du général testeurs c'est aussi
celle de marco ferreri qui tourne
actuellement un épisode de la guerre de
sécession à paris devant l'église
saint-eustache un paradoxe peut être pas
l'avis du général custer est un peu à
l'image de nos propres destruction et le
champ de bataille des halles finit par
ressembler à l'ouest devrait nous faire
qu'on peut être regretter aussi n'était
pas comme ça en tout cas c'était moins
dur ensemble erreur quelqu'un qui aime
la guerre dans candide dangereux sont
considérés désir est généralement ces
gens là mais nous on ne considère pas de
zorro en tout cas on n'aime pas les lots
dont le général perry était le super un
le supérieur hiérarchique du colonel
koster et qu'il avait fait un plan de
bataille que questerre n'a pas subit
d'ailleurs voilà l'historique et basta
heureusement d'autres une jeune
infirmière
franck il ya trier les pprl qu'un
qui est un grand coup de coude sur le
canal cost oui
que faire
planté
suis intégré parce que je suis un indien
qui habite à paris il ya un boutique
avec sa famille et j'ai jour leurs rôles
de prendre deux admirateurs des généraux
carter je suis tout à fait nous sommes
ce qu'il faut pour qu'il ne faudrait pas
tout à fait nié je suis également sans
cheveux parce que pour les indiens un
homme sans cheveux n'est pas un homme et
je joue dans ce film le rôle du fou est
avec eux sortent un peu comme le fou du
roi celui qui dit la vérité avec un
certain humour
il fallut big four fra auber
on croit que c'était un héros mais c'est
un pauvre hère comme vous dites en
français tollé vous avez déjà vraiment
très bon nous exigeons des hommes nous
cacher pour absolument se demander merci
beaucoup je suis moi même plus est ce
que vous en ont dénombré outre le fils
du président bush entretinrent away par
les hommes ce temps des images et des
sons à mes yeux absolument merveilleux
de le dépasser en vous ferez merci est
rarement au général c'est veut dire
aussi bonne punition slipper
aussi
mouais
alors oui mais voilà eh ben
je vivais des rivières dans mobile et
jarmo jean bonne dernière
8les à liège et je mets des
les journaux dedans voilà
et puis je marche au feeling
dors je mange
et d'ambiance fashion sur avis sur tous
ces comédiens pronostiqué des gorgones
pronostic est mort douce tantôt stick et
et peuvent être moi de vous dire au
revoir
voilà